by the time the Second World War ended
in 1945 Europe was in ruins the daunting
task of rebuilding and planning a better
future began the 1950s brought a spirit
of new beginnings and robert schumann
the french foreign minister gave a
speech outlining a vision of France West
Germany Italy and the Benelux countries
sharing strategic resources in order to
build a lasting peace in Europe when you
later
at the Treaty of Paris the European Coal
and Steel community was founded a common
steel and coal market was freely set
market prices and without import or
export duties the first manifestation of
the European community was born the need
for an external representation for the
newly formed European community was
apparent right from the start when John
mone set up a transatlantic office in
1954 the first foundation stone of the
external relations of the European
community was laid Europe's first steps
to be present in the wider world
coincided with the dismantling of
European empires beginning in 1957 with
the independence of Ghana the Treaty of
Rome that year recognized the
relationship of the founding six members
to their overseas territories mainly in
Africa a five-year development fund was
set up this fund was used for capital
aid programs to develop infrastructure
like roads hospitals and schools
contract teams administering the funds
were typically drawn from European
engineering consultancies resident in
the countries but the old colonial
empires were changing both for the
European colonial powers and the newly
independent nations the Commission's
contract teams soon found themselves
dealing with new issues especially in
Africa where nearly independent
countries sought to establish diplomatic
relations with Europe during the 1960's
a new relationship was formalized under
the unday conventions
and a post-colonial development
agreement was established the European
Development Fund the contract teams were
replaced by a new agency the European
agency for cooperation from 1965 onwards
21 offices were established in the
Associated countries these officers were
charged with implementing the grant aid
of the new fund dealing mainly with
internal development issues in Europe
the effects of the cold war intensified
with the building of what was to become
the iconic symbol of the Cold War the
Berlin Wall while in Western Europe
walls were coming down in 1968 the
customs union was completed and goods
now passed freely and unchecked across
the borders of the Member States in the
mid-1970s the first law made convention
was signed between Europe and forty six
founding African Caribbean and Pacific
states
lo mein was a modern International
partnership convention
replacing the old post-colonial model
long way redefined the relationship
between Europe and developing countries
it addressed more than just development
cooperation now trade regional
integration political issues and
cultural cooperation were on the agenda
European delegation offices were charged
specifically with the responsibility of
implementing the Roma Convention and to
the number of these delegations doubled
the European community continued to grow
with the accession of Ireland the UK and
Denmark the mid-70s also saw the signing
of community protocols with eight
southern and eastern Mediterranean
countries the relationship and attention
given to Latin America was strengthened
when Spain and Portugal joined stronger
ties were also developed in Asia Europe
became more professional in its dealings
with the rest of the world an
international European personality was
steadily being created to deal with the
changing world by 1980 there were 50
delegation offices around the world
delegations opened at the rate of five a
year as Europe took an increasing role
in world affairs the need for a common
foreign policy became more pressing and
a common foreign and security policy was
eventually formalized in 1992 by the
Maastricht Treaty the end of the Cold
War forced further changes to foreign
policy in light of the problems faced by
Europe in reacting to the conflicts that
erupted after the fall of the Berlin
Wall in 1989 particularly in the former
Yugoslavia the EU created a European
security and defence policy a rethink of
the external service led to a major
overhaul in 1998 when the Amsterdam
treaty established the position of High
Representative we have to move towards a
more active and less declaratory foreign
policy I would head to be matched by
deeds Europe began to intensify its
efforts to play an international
political and security role more in line
with its economic status military or
police forces were now sent to areas of
crisis to carry out humanitarian
operations peacekeeping crisis
management and even peacemaking military
action could also be carried out by an
EU Rapid Reaction Force the fall of the
communist regimes also demanded a
response
the EU set up programs to help the
transition to democratic market
orientated economies the implementation
of these programs coincided with the
establishment of new delegation offices
across Central and Eastern Europe Europe
also looked to its southern and Middle
Eastern neighbours in 1995 the 15 member
states of the EU came together with 12
governments from the region the
euro-mediterranean partnership promoted
democracy human rights and cooperation
among the partners now in 2007 the EU
has expanded to 27 member states
effectively pushing the European border
further east to a new set of neighbors
the European neighbourhood policy
emerged to help the --use neighbors
benefit from the possibilities offered
by an enlarged EU and to support their
own reforms today the EU is the world's
largest donor of development assistance
accounting for more than half of the
world's official aid the external
service has 130 delegations and 5000
members of staff presenting explaining
and implementing the --use external
policy today Europe has a global reach
facilitating trade and development
supporting human rights and free
elections in order to promote democratic
values we have to work with all our
partners in order to make issues go
forward and thus bring the international
community together and the more we can
do the more effective we will be this is
what we call effective multilateralism
for 50 years the European dream has
ensured peace on the continent in a
world of global threats and challenges
the Europe of the 21st century will
continue to tackle the current concerns
of its citizens such as the economy
quality of life and security it will
also become a stronger global player
committed to multilateralism
using its foreign policy tools of aid
trade and economic agreements to promote
human rights democracy freedom and
justice throughout the world